et
bonjour bienvenue dans votre émission
montre moi un signe ça va
tous les jours des entendants et des
sources croisent et ne communique pas
je vais vous montrer les signes pour
rétablir la communication et l'améliorer
bonjour madame bonjour je suis sourde
vous êtes soldes
je voudrais une baguette s'il vous plaît
vous voulez un croissant un croissant
non ça c'est un croissant une baguette
elle n'a pas compris
ce n'est pas un croissant ce n'est pas
un pain au chocolat
ce n'est pas un pain aux raisins c'est
facile c'est simple une baguette on va
voir on va essayer une baguette
on va voir si elle arrive à comprendre
une baguette voilà l a compris
merci bonjour boulangerie croissant
pains au chocolat pas aux raisins
baguette
portable
merci au revoir bonjour madame bonjour
je suis sourde
vous comprenez la langue des signes
non désolé mais je peux vous aider
cette robe bleue
je la voudrait en jaune vous n'aimez pas
celle d'accord
celle là
c'est pas ça pas vers je voudrais du
jaune
désolé je ne comprends pas elle n'a pas
compris il y à différents signes pour
les couleurs je veux du jaune
c'est ça le signe de jaune
je vais essayer dominé
jaune c'est comme le soleil le soleil du
soleil a le soleil et jaune
elle a trouvé jaune jaune
bonjour mot couleur3 offert aux jeunes
bleu vert
rouge bois
blanc revoir à bientôt